bonjour je n'ai darsières bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en tant que militante
historique du parti progressiste
martiniquais militante historique ou
vieille militante qui s'ouvrirait comme
appellation mais n'est pas que laquelle
nous puisque toutes les deux sont vraies
alors stop et pml qui célèbre en ce
moment c'est 50 de ventes
vous êtes avec nos parts il ne vous a
pas échappé jany darsières que le
progressisme est une notion très
tendance en ce moment quand vous quand
vous vous avez posé les idées du parti
progressiste martiniquais 1966 s'était
croit être progressiste
aussi je ne vais pas répondre en ce qui
concerne le progressisme
c'est une notion philosophique que
j'ignore ne ce n'est pas dans mon nez
dans ma formation dans mon éducation
je préfère les valeurs progressistes
vous m'avez demandé ce qui a changé
non je vous demandais ce que c'était au
départ ce qui a changé au départ je vais
peut-être vous décevoir mais ça n'a pas
changé c'est exactement les mêmes choses
qui nous guide qui nous conduisent à une
prise de conscience absolument essentiel
et touvier tout vient vraiment d'aimé
césaire ce aimé césaire ne vous a pas
échappé qui a qui a créé le parti
progressiste martiniquais 1958 et toutes
les idées qu'il a exprimés
c'est un héritage que nous cultivons
avec amour et passion
vous avez quand même vu une chantal
maignan par exemple faire son apparition
sur la scène politique martiniquaise
avec cette notion de droite progressiste
est-ce que vous l'approuvez ça mais
pourquoi pas non je ne nie pas du tour
que à doigts qu'il peut y avoir des gens
qui sont qui ont des idées de progrès
pour faire avancer une cause faire
avancer la menthe unique c'est comme ça
que je ne prends n'importe qui peut dire
aujourd'hui qu'il importe croire il dit
qu'il se revendique et progressiste
alors oui mais n'est pas autant qu'ils
ne le fait pas et je crois que
les gens qui ont été formés dans cette
pensée d'aimé césaire ne ne disent pas
n'importe quoi nous sommes guidés par
des valeurs qui quels sont ces valeurs
aujourd'hui
eh bien écoutez d'abord hier aujourd'hui
hier c'était vraiment dans le statut du
parti progressiste martiniquais très
clairement exprimés le parti
progressiste martiniquais est un parti
de gauche à idéal socialiste et
anticolonialiste je crois que tout est
tout est dit dans ce terme alors toute
personne qui sent qu'il ya une fibre
anti colonialiste c'est-à-dire pour
dénoncer des injustices est fondamentale
toute personne qui sans qu' il y a des
idées sociales a développé peut être
effectivement n'ont pas non pas du ppm
mais accompagnant le ppm dans ses
valeurs ses salaires sont de meilleurs
opérationnel emmanuel macron du
mouvement en marche revendiquent aussi
de cette idée du de valeurs
progressistes comme vous dites mais je
sais qu anime parler de monsieur mâcon
mais forcément non mais c'est passé sans
problème je suis très contente mais
c'est très bien on verra à l'épreuve
pour le moment nous sommes un petit peu
gêné par le fait qu'ils disent n'est ni
de gauche ni de droite mais si al sirr
ce qu'il fait dans la transversalité
voilà s'appelle façon de noyer le
poisson ne plus être quelque part d'être
de partout peut-être que mes jeunes
grands maîtres je ne suis pas une
citoyenne française je suis une
citoyenne martiniquaise
et je regarde je suis vigilante
j'accepte l'autre camp c'est ce que
césaire nous a appris à accepter l'autre
de plus l'ajout du plu et toi au plus
large et nous allons voir ce que cela va
donner mais progressisme jamais
darsières on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
ça ne l'a pas un autre nom ce qu'on
appelle tout simplement le zonage de
circonstance peut-être mais en fait ce
n'est pas notre cas je ne sais pas
j'attends de voir je ne je ne porte pas
de jugement je n'ai pas de préjugés de
près jugé au sens profond du terme
j'attends de voir ce que monsieur macron
va proposer à la france et aux français
pour s'opposer à son meeting lorsqu'il
est favori non c'est pas parce que je
crois en ce qui me concerne ce n'était
pas par adhésion c'était par curiosité
c'est un homme politique jeune dynamique
qui viennent à la martinique
je voulais entendre effectivement ce
qu'il proposait d'autres faits gitana
désir d'autres viendraient vous seriez
allé par curiosité avoué son filion non
non je ne serais pas allé à fillon non
je ne serai pas à lié à marine le pen
dit j'espère qu'elle ne vienne l'a
jamais c'est mon voeu le plus cher en
tout cas ce progressisme transversale à
séduire le voit avec par exemple les
soutiens de martinique est vous
connaissez il ya eric hop est daniel
chaumet fred lordinot des soutiens ce
leader dedans marche
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en partie pour
résister martinique et ce sont des
personnalités locales qui ont été quand
même exclu parce qu'ils ont apporté un
soutien trop massif à emmanuel macron
non corrigeant il n'a pas été exclue
suspens 10 ans était suspendu c'est très
important
ils ont été suspendus et c'est leur
droit d'avoir une opinion qui n'est pas
celle de la majorité ce qu'on leur
reproche je crois savoir mais je ne suis
pas de la direction du parti ce qu'on
leur reproche je crois savoir c'est
d'avoir et urbi et orbi de proclamer
cette adhésion et humilité
alors que le parti progressiste qui
était aussi leur parti avait proposé un
autre mot d'ordre
oui mais ils disent justement que le
débat n'existe pas sur les parties est
ce que justement là le pp ne doit pas
faire ne fera pas face à une nouvelle
crise qui risque de remettre tous en
question
il ya eu quand même une scission
dernièrement avec au sein du ppm qui a
donné le rdv claude lise ce cas on n'est
pas dans un cas de figure qui risque de
donner à cette situation je ne vois pas
un métier vient je ne crois pas les
esprits sont échauffés vous voyez bien
que nous sommes dans une confusion
générale
regardez ce qui se passe en france d'un
au parti socialiste d'un à droite au
mime un chez les la droite locale qui
est des visées pourquoi pourquoi nous
pourquoi nous ne participèrent à cette
confusion ça c'est ça c'est évident mais
ça les craintes du sou ne sommes pas
d'ébranler questionnant les challenges
pour le parti progressiste martiniquais
aujourd'hui en 2017 quelles sont les
anges des challenges des dangers
peut-être culpa pour le ppm aujourd'hui
les enjeux
c'est ce sont toujours les mêmes c'est à
dire proclamer notre différence
aucun mais notre doigt à l'initiative
proclamer notre envie de plus de
responsabilité dans la gestion de ce
pays tout le monde
je ne sais pas si tout le monde dit ça
mais le parti progressiste martiniquais
dit cela et le pense profondément
et il y as et en général y compris les
camarades dont jeudi les camarades chômé
lordinot ils sont et coupe est ils sont
je pense sur cette même ligne
cependant ils ont une différence
d'appréciation au point de le voir comme
des brebis égarées une des différences
d'appréciation sur la sueur sur le
comment dirais-je la gestion actuelle du
ppmc leur point de vue est également sur
le choix en ce qui concerne les
présidentielles répond-t-il se remettre
en question mais le le ppm semaine se
remet toujours en question lorsque aimé
césaire a quitté la vie politique
officiellement puisqu'ils étaient âgés
et qui n'étaient plus maire de fort de
force et bien qu'est ce qu'on a dit le
ppm va disparaître le crcm et est en
partie le pépin ce n'est pas le cas
serge letchimy et deux cabanes ce n'est
pas serge letchimy seulement et tout le
parti derrière lui y compris ses
camarades
nous avons travaillé pour que affirmer
notre personnalité pour affirmer qu'il
ya une peuple qui constitue une nation
et qui veut avoir des prérogatives
particulières
nous ne sommes pas ébranlée nous avons
connu beaucoup nous avons connu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup mieux
exactement vous êtes un militant depuis
1966 vous avez envie de continuer à
mériter toujours partie en aimant
passionnément
je serai toujours jusqu'à ma mort je
pense une militante progressiste parce
que vous avez peur pour la martinique
un petit peu pourquoi pas et bien parce
que justement ce que c est à nous a
appris ses tenues humanisme profond
or je vois trop d'austérité trop de
haine trop de confusion est en réalité
nous sommes même peuple sortie de l'
esclavage ayant connu toutes les
souffrances du monde
et nous devrions aller de l'avant toute
personne qui se met en travers mais kate
merci d'avoir été avec nos jeunes y
darsières merci d'avoir été avec nous
vous êtes non du ppm depuis 1966 merci
bonne journée
[Musique]